hey everyone
did you know that although bitcoin was
the first cryptocurrency in operation
for the general public there are many
different kinds of cryptocurrencies
available depending on their formulation
or code design
application or use case and other
criteria there are at least eight
different sorts of cryptocurrencies that
we can distinguish
so here i am to take you through a new
video on the types of cryptocurrency by
simply learn to enlighten you more on
the interesting topic
so let's get started with the video but
uh before moving
do subscribe to our youtube channel
simply learn and hit the bell icon to
never miss an update from simply learn
now let's
quickly go through the agenda slide
so first we will have a quick
introduction to what is cryptocurrency
following that we will have a crisp
comparison between
coin and token
then we will look into the types of
cryptocurrency
and at the end of the video we will
explore why do we need to have so many
types of cryptocurrency
so let's start the video so the first
thing that we are going to understand is
what is cryptocurrency
now a digital payment system known as
cryptocurrency doesn't rely on banks to
validate transactions peer-to-peer
technology makes it possible for anybody
anywhere to send and receive payments
payments made using cryptocurrencies do
not exist as actual physical coins that
can be transported and exchanged rather
they only exist as digital entries to an
online database that details individual
transactions
now a public ledger keeps track of all
these cryptocurrency transactions that
involve money transfers digital wallets
are where cryptocurrencies actually
stored
so now that we know what cryptocurrency
is let's break it down and compare the
two most basic forms of cryptocurrency
that is
coin and token
now coin and token are phrases that are
regularly used while talking about
cryptocurrencies but there is a
distinction even if they may sound
similar
so maintaining their integrity is
crucial so now let's have a quick look
at the differences
so the first one is a digital coin
functions similarly to traditional
currency and is created on its own
blockchain it can be used as a means of
trade between two parties conducting
business together and a way to store
value bitcoins and litecoin are a few
examples of points
on the other hand tokens are much more
versatile than merely digital currency
tokens can be used as a software
application component such as to allow
access to an app confirm identification
or track goods as they move through a
supply chain
they are generated on top of an existing
blockchain like nfts they can represent
digital art
second is coins require significant
resources and skills to create
themselves whereas tokens are relatively
easy to create
third coins are mostly distributed using
the mining process
and tokens are distributed using icos
coming to the next one
coins are used to store and transfer
money on the other hand tokens are used
for various purposes like security and
asset representation
and the fifth is coins can be validated
by any merchant who uses them and one
merchant validates tokens
so now that we have reached the most
crucial part of this video the types of
cryptocurrency let's discuss them one by
one
so despite being used to describe all
varieties of digital or cryptocurrency
the term cryptocurrencies is frequently
used interchangeably with coins they are
frequently considered as such even
though most of them aside from bitcoin
does not function as a unit of account
or a store of value or a medium of
exchange
so technically there are eight types of
cryptocurrencies security tokens
utility tokens payment tokens
exchange tokens non-punchable tokens
d5 tokens or decentralized finance
tokens
stable coins asset-backed tokens and
privacy tokens
so let's start with the security tokens
now these cryptocurrencies are
securitized and
derive their value from an external
asset that can be sold as security by
financial regulations as a result they
are utilized to securitize the
tokenization of real estate bonds stocks
real estate and other currencies from
the real world to protect user
investments financial regulators must
therefore supervise and regulate the
exchange issuance dealings values
tokenization backing and trading of
transactions due to the nature
now security tokens basically stand in
for an interest a share of stock or
equity voting rights and a dividend
right in the asset they represent
owners or holders share in the profits
made by the issuers or managerial
choices
through security token offerings they
are distributed now they can be used
when investors require immediate
settlement open management asset
division or etc
now security tokens are further divided
into equity tokens and asset bank tokens
now equity tokens resemble conventional
stocks in appearance and operation
except that ownership and transfer are
carried out digitally dividends from
managerial and issuer choices and
actions are due to investors debt tokens
represent short-term loans with fixed
interest rates
now coming to asset bank token
these have an underlying worth that is
supported by actual real estate
works of art
carbon
credits or commodities
they possess qualities similar to those
of gold silver oil etc they can be
exchanged extra
examples of security tokens are sea
advanced bcap and science blockchain
now following
security tokens we have utility tokens
now utility tokens are simply digital
units that reflect a value on the
blockchain and are sometimes thought of
as a coupon or vouchers to put it
another way the token grants specific
access to a good or service offered by
the token issuer by purchasing the token
a person can acquire access to the
product or service and exchange it for a
specified access value
now the holder does not get ownership
but rather the right to a good a service
with an equivalent value to the token
for instance as long as they own the
token they can
access the good
or service for a reduced cost or for
free
in some jurisdictions a cryptocurrency
classified as a utility token is exempt
from financial regulations
now some of the examples of utility
tokens are fun fair basic attention
token brick block timmy coin
sharing lab token and golem
so following this comes payment tokens
now payment tokens are used to transact
directly between buyers and sellers
so uh
the products and services on digital
marketplaces as opposed to via middlemen
as is common in traditional banking and
finance
of course the bulk of cryptocurrencies
and tokens fit within this category
whether they are security or utility
tokens not all the utility tokens can
also function as payment tokens
now
payment tokens are not secure attires
and can not be purchased as such
as a result they're not considered asset
security subject to financial
regulations they might or might not
insure holders access to any present or
future goods or services
example of payment tokens monero
ethereum and bitcoin
next is non-fungible tokens
now a non-tangible token is a blockchain
based digital certificate of ownership
for a singular non-replaceable item or
one that cannot be traded with another
asset
it is created using the same technology
as other types of tokens still it is
primarily used to represent a work of
art images audio video collectibles real
estate virtual words memes gifs digital
content like post and tweets
now nfd marketplaces like openc radable
foundation and decent lan are where you
may buy and sell them
popularity monetizing goods royalty
payments whenever their work is sold
to a new user partial ownership of
expensive assets
auctioning to raise money
creating memorable movements or
preserving histories for market motives
like trading and celebrity issuing are
all included in this application
now some of the examples of nfts are
logan paul's videos clips twitter
founder jack dorsey's first tweets nft
every day is the first 5000 days drawing
by mike winkelmann better known as
people and several crypto kitties
now following that we have d5 tokens or
we can call decentralized finance tokens
now decentralized finance refers to the
financial applications or dabs built on
the blockchain or distributed ledger
which makes them distributed and those
that render financial and money control
directly to the user while allowing them
to transact globally with peer-to-peers
methods and access to global markets
now anyone with internet access can
access these d5 apps each defy app runs
on a token economy that is supported by
a native token
these tokens are a programmable currency
where developer may add logic to how
transaction and payments are made
rv chain link uni swap polka dot and
solana just a few examples of popular
decentralized finance tokens
now decentralized exchanges storage
sharing and apps for lending are some
examples of d5 application types
following this we have stable coins
now these tokens are of stable value in
nature as their nature implies meaning
that their value is reasonably
predictable in that it essentially never
changes
stable tokens or stable coins as they
are more commonly known are backed by an
asset with a relatively consistent value
such as cash so we have stable coins
that are pegged to the dollar and the
euro as well as tokens backed by
commodities like oil gold and other
precious metals
stable coins assist in eradicating
assets or even other digital currency in
stability stable coins include back
source and tether which are all backed
by usd cash in a one to one ratio along
with true sd gemi dollar and usd coin as
table coins packed by gold keto gold
tether gold
digix global and gold coin
then comes asset backed tokens
now the term asset bank tokens refers
to a class of cryptocurrency
whose underlying value is supported by a
real-world asset such as cash stocks
bonds property gold and precious metals
on blockchain they are utilized to
represent and trade the value of these
underlying assets digitally
so due to the way the underlying assets
are used in transactions most of these
are provided as security tokens the
equity token offer is the primary method
of issuing them
examples of asset-backed tokens are oil
coin which tokenizes barrels of oil held
in reserve petroleum coin
zn ink oil token etc
the energy web token tokenized energy
green energy token by w
bpp etc are some of its examples
and now comes the last but not the least
that is privacy tokens
now these cryptocurrencies are used for
privacy applications as their name
implies because they have superior
privacy promoting programming to bitcoin
and other popular cryptocurrencies
better anonymity in crypto transaction
is necessary for various reasons
including the right to privacy security
investigations are extremely sensitive
transactions
yet they are also utilized in fraud and
crime these cryptocurrencies use a
variety of strategies like currency
mixing offering transactions and
anonymity mechanisms like coin join to
ensure transaction privacy
some of the examples of privacy tokens
are monero z cash dash horizon beam and
verge
so now that we have covered all the
necessary types of cryptocurrencies now
let's understand why we need so many
types of cryptocurrency
so since the source code for blockchain
technologies available to everyone any
software developer can utilize it to
build new things developers have done
just that
at the time of this writing there are
reportedly more than 10 000 different
cryptocurrencies in use and the number
keeps rising
for comparison just
four years ago more than one thousand
cryptocurrencies existed
there are so many cryptocurrencies now
because of the underlying blockchain
technology it allows programmers to
design various coins with the range of
features
so this was all about types of
cryptocurrency i hope you liked this
video and learned something new from it
i hope you found this video informative
uh please do like this video and
subscribe to our youtube channel if you
have any questions please feel free to
ask them in our comment section our team
will reach out to you as soon as
possible thank you and stay safe
[Music]
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn youtube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos turn it up and get certified
click here